there's another amazing performer who's
coming back donny osmond back on stage
in las vegas he's got a new residency
over at harrah's he's also got a new
album out start again is his 65th what
studio album who knew that's not a typo
uh yeah he performed whatever you want
from any one of those albums in his
residency
in the show i put all 65 albums on that
huge screen behind me and anyone in the
audience could pick any album and pick
any song from that album and we do it
and we'll do maybe 30 seconds of it so
we get to about four or five songs
it is nothing but 10 minutes of improv
and
the band hates me because they have to
know all these songs and i forget some
of the lyrics but we do it
it's it's such a fun part of the show
my gosh it'd be like four or five
hundred songs
right donny osmond is performing now at
harrah's he's got a ton of shows on the
books through november then he'll take a
little break for the holidays return to
the stage in late january tickets are
still available